vous semblez préféré vanessa paradis
votre carrière d'actrice à votre
carrière de chanteuse
8 le cinéma c'est les vacances de la
personnalité on devient quelqu'un
d'autre on est très entourée c'est vrai
alors que chanteuse
c'est d'une extrême solitude non mais en
plus je préfère pas je ne préfère pas
assez là les projets l'avion que ça se
présente comme ça et puis je ne met plus
de temps à faire les chansons maintenant
parce que je les fais un petit peu moins
avec l'aide d'autres personnes et donc
ça me prend du temps ce que j'essaie les
factures icc l'on vous dit je ne suis
pas gainsbourg et puis les enfants
prennent beaucoup de temps
c'est moi qui vais prendre beaucoup de
temps avec mon enfant parce que je n'ai
rien envie de louper
je suis accusé levez-vous même quoi un
pas je suis déjà allé faire élever par
d'autres préfèrent les élevez vous même
n'avez pauvres
alors question cinéma quand même vous
venez de tourner avec le scénariste de
la fille sur le pont qui s'appelle ça
serait manquer qui a réalisé son premier
film away est un petit bijou et c'est
encore quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup qui
a écrit acquis écrit une histoire
sublimer je viens juste de fêter un peu
le tour n'est donc c'est encore assez
frais avec un jeune acteur qui s'appelle
vincent rottiers il faut retenir son
parce que c'est une une bombe atomique
est une perle aura il a 17 ans et c est
ce que tu as son portable à vincent
rottiers un attaché de presse
on va demander qu'il appelle pourtant
appelé instamment invité tout de suite
alors en tous les cas si on peut dire
vanessa c'est vous fait pas d'effort
particulier pour tournée en amérique au
dj aucune ambition internationale vous
ai même pas d'agent hollywood non
pourquoi
mais parce que j'ai faim ils ont déjà
ils ont des gens très très bien ils ont
pas franchement besoin de quoi qu'ils
ont besoin nous sommes à moins que ce
soit un projet enfin quelque chose de
spécial mais faire la course au progrès
j'ai l'impression que tout le temps at
leur moi qui tourne quand même une fois
tous les 36 du mois la banque pourrait
tourner tout le monde tout le temps pour
jamais quand vous oubliez puis parce que
je franchement jules moi j'ai tout ce
qu'il me faut ici en france puis j'ai un
peu plus l'europe pourquoi je voyage je
n'ai pas déjà ça me prend beaucoup de
temps
s'il fallait en plus que je fasse ça là
bas puis c'est bien là bas on ne montre
pas du doigt
si vous êtes sages finalement non c'est
pas vrai six mois si elle élève ses
enfants elle veut pas faire la course à
hollywood c'est assez sage non je suis
très normal c'est très ennuyeux c'est
bien non pas du tout enfin je sais pas
ce qu'en pense votre johnny depp mais
moi personnellement je trouve ça bien
apparemment fait longtemps que cet
ensemble soit quand même temps si c'est
bien déjà et vous michel depuis combien
de temps et votre femme
trois mois alors vous avez passé
déjà ça va c'est romancé les trois
premiers mois c'est les plus originales
nous vivons ensemble depuis trois mois
oui nous sommes pas mariés encore un 3 -
et les noces de bistrot non
vanessa est toujours pas mariés n'ont
plus jamais ça j'ai des enfants alors
vanessa vous n'avez toujours pas de
projet avec johnny depp qui a eu cette
histoire de don quichotte pour laquelle
nous avons reçu jean rochefort ici
l'année dernière pour la sortie du dvd
bon aventure avortée terrible histoire
évidemment et c'est vrai qu'après le
succès de pirates des caraïbes qui a
fait quand même 621 millions de dollars
de recettes énormes
la suite est déjà en chantier donc vivre
là il a happé par sa est en fait
effectivement vous concentrer sur votre
rôle de maman surtout à los angeles où
passez votre entre les cours de danse
pour les enfants les ateliers d'arts
plastiques pour les enfants
le pédiatre pour les enfants et les
enfants et un poney club là bas mais
c'est bien tout le monde mais bref bien
ses proches ainsi vous pourriez de la
coke au queen tous les soirs on vous
féliciteraient pas maintenant alors
entre deux tournages vous avez votre
maison avec johnny depp dans le sud de
la france
nous vous reposer un petit peu voilà la
drees qui passe
oui les déviations d'accès pour visage
qu'elle demanderait alors vous dites on
va au marché en cuisinant mangent ils
ont une vie encore terriblement simple
vous vivez une espèce de bohème très
chic un petit peu comme dans les années
70 c'est rockstar d'idées comme ça quand
vous voyagez avec johnny depp et comme
30 valise qui vous suivent que j'aime
c'est pareil en voyage mais celle aussi
où il ya des freins les meubles non par
exemple gt2 un exemple oran le drap qui
recouvre la table a longé par exemple ce
n'est pas important que les enfants
soient habitués la couleur du drap
vanessa prend ce drap tu vois là c'est
tout ça c'est vrai ah c'est beau quand
vous dites ça mais non mais aussi parce
que moi j'en les enfants et vivent une
vie
on n'aura pas tellement de demander leur
avis ne sont pas l'air de s'en plaindre
mais il faut quand même pas les jeux
l'échangé de maison sans arrêt sans
qu'ils aient des choses ici ils
reconnaissent qu'on a pour patron
vanessa paradis et johnny depp ch et un
couple parfait
c'est le bonheur absolu donc on va faire
une interview je fous la merde
j'ai toujours amoureuse de johnny depp
n'est toujours pas mariés donc vous
serez pas qu'il est un peu moins bon sur
man city font c'est vrai qu'il a une
vilaine verrues plantaires
c'est un dommage d'être tout le temps
séparés dans sérieux justement n'est pas
tout le temps il néglige pas là non non
c'est caen qui vous ai dit je t'aime
pour la dernière fois vous avez cadeau
qui vous a fait c'est quoi une valise
non je sais pas si j'ai des belles roses
pour la fête des morts il vachement
attentionné quand ils offrent des fleurs
il dit pas sa secrétaire de le faire
c'est lui qui va vraiment les achetés au
magasin il n'oublie jamais votre
anniversaire je vis de votre en compte
non plus non mais cécile internet pour
savoir s'il est parfait moi je vous le
confirme tout de suite et il est parfait
vous engueuler parfois quand même bien
sûr ils oublient de relever la cuvette
des toilettes
non jamais menacé un mec formidable non
sérieusement c'est quoi qui vous énerve
le plus chez lui qu'on le fasse pas nous
il a des défauts mais je
j'aime ses défauts d'accord ils
voulaient mais il est pardonné il laisse
traîner ses chaussettes
bah ouais mais j'aimerais pas qui
arrange tout ca dragons ont pu nommer
fait d'accord vous êtes fan de but et on
va dire il a un petit peu un tempérament
de feu
ouais et qui sait pas toujours très
facile mais ça me plaît c'est qui allo
bassan routier sa bulle c'est laurent
baffie tué sur paris là où il peut
passer
oui bonjour vincent menthol qui on est à
l'antenne
tu es sur paris est ce que tu peux
passer s'il te plaît à la plaine saint
denis
c'est vanessa l'annoncé man et saint
paradis qui a parlé de toi l'addict
était formidable et je te la passe
d'antoine pol qu on t'attend
moi aussi je t'embrasse je te passe
vanessa non mais c'est toi
non mais c'est mais ouais mais je n'y
suis pour rien j'ai juste voulu dire des
jeux d'hiver
en plus c'est un jeu de venir maintenant
ils veulent que tu n'en vient pas du
repas du soir
[Applaudissements]
au moment où wayne mais il ya plein mon
nom mais il a mieux à faire il à la fête
de la musique c'est ça c'est bien cette
semaine tandis que la faille à la tête
du top amoureuse de lui mais j'ai
beaucoup de tendresse pour lui je
l'adoré v5 bien et c'est ainsi pas sonné
samedi a pu la fête de la musique c'est
monaco qui vient à l'est vanessa je
t'adore ça jusqu'à johnny depp jeu
serait jaloux mois elle tu adores l
habitat 18 balles étaient hyper mignon à
la dig up
il venait d'avoir 18 ans à la même
chanté enfin il dit que c'est une belle
aventure avec toi mais qui passe de
minutes à nous raconter bon tout à
l'heure on t'attend je crois qu'il va
passer de mettre les choses au point
bon
de deux trois petites questions qui va
là donc il est parfait c'est johnny depp
évidemment il râle pas quand il faut
descendre la poubelle non mais râler
il a des mamies qui vous énerve quand
même oh là là quand même y en a quand
même à vous l'avez déjà chopé en train
de regarder un film porno non non bon
ben c'est sans espoir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu